esports has been around long enough now
to create some truly ridiculous records
who has the most headshots ever who's
lost the most games in a row which team
has made the most money some of these
records are being broken all the time
but others might just be unbeatable
before we get into this make sure you're
subscribed to the score esports that way
you'll never miss a video just like this
one and with that let's get into our
list of the top 10 most insane esports
records
starting us off at number 10 is scream
who holds the highest headshot
percentage in csgo because the ct side
is their better side it's their t-side
where they really struggle
everyone knows scream is a human head
shot machine and it turns out the stats
back him up that is one player down for
game religion
but there is the one tap machine not
male functioning at all right now out of
every kill scream has ever gotten an
impressive 68.1 percent of them have
been headshots according to hltv aiming
is a crucial part of counter-strike and
being able to click enemy heads more
accurately than others can be the
difference between life and death but
now you can see scream doesn't care
anymore screams doing the respect for
quick headshots and the ace that's
beautifully done that is sick scream has
been able to cultivate a career based on
his ability to pop heads better than
anyone else and his signature one taps
have become legendary within the cs go
community he's got one bullet in it he's
three legs got one bullet oh
scream
just scream things on purpose not all of
these records were going to be good
achievements because at number nine we
have a guy that holds the record for the
shortest professional esports career
apto bye bye
for those who don't know the story apto
was a korean solo queue god some said
his skills even rivalled fakers but
since he didn't play pro no one ever
knew the truth that is until he formed
team dark and finally got his shot at
glory unfortunately aptos years of elo
boosting finally caught up to him when
he was banned from tournaments by riot
for two years before he took the stage
for his first match yes aptos career
ended before it even began
[Music]
but it doesn't stop there apto also
holds the record for the longest defined
ban in esports because his personal riot
account was banned for 1 000 years and
as a result of apto getting banned the
rest of team dark basically gave up and
memed away their one and only appearance
one of those throne games actually ended
up holding the record for league's
shortest professional match talk about a
triple threat the fastest game of league
of legends in history easily i'm just
gonna make that claim i don't even care
there it is gg in eight minutes 24
seconds samsung ozone takes down team
dark aka team cloud templar here on
champions winter
sticking with the negativity now and
number eight record is truly
heartbreaking it's shanghai dragons
holding the longest losing streak in
esports
he opens up the account there wrapping
around the back side he's found another
one all tricks missing make it three for
righty qd oh he'll take four
oh wait a minute coming to life and
that'll do it the san francisco shock
will sweep the series four and zero
welcome back everyone to the desk here
for the post game as the san francisco
shock will win 4-0 and that means that
the shanghai dragons are oh and 40 in
the season in the overwatch league's
inaugural season the shanghai dragons
went 0 and 40 losing every single game
some even consider it 42 games if you
count the two pre-season matches they
lost either way it's impressive this is
all on diaz saving a blink to touch the
point keep overtime alive but that's
pretty much it with the whole house
using used to zone them out
the los angeles valiants win the match
four to zero and keep their hopes alive
for the playoffs
not only is this the longest losing
streak in esports history it's one of
the longest losing streaks period unless
we're counting international cricket
none of the big four traditional sports
even come close to this dismal record
last but not least well it is kind of
the least it is different dragons police
dear dragons
gg afk have a nice summer that's about
it fun story if the dragons were afk all
season they would have the same record
the shanghai dragons finally won their
first official match in game three of
season two now they basically had to
replace their entire team and coaching
staff to get this win so depending on
who you ask the original shanghai
dragons still haven't won a single game
just a couple more percent go let them
have it boston axiom on the primal rage
but it does not matter ladies and
gentlemen history has been made the
shanghai dragons and the 43rd intestine
managed to pick up their first match
victory
grab your favorite snack and strap in
because our seventh spot goes to the
longest professional esports match
cloud9 vs scary faces at the starladder
12 qualifiers
he's getting so low he's gonna go down
that's a kill oh no static stomp on to
pose seven and cut the punches there's
the side he's dead as well two heroes
down and oh no no stop the music we'll
reset right okay now there's a few
contenders for the longest match in
esports but when we look at
uninterrupted play time this 200 minute
game of dota has the competition beat i
mean i i really don't see this game
ending because they're not in any
different kind of situation so they were
an arrow
that's right for almost three and a half
hours these poor souls traded kills back
and forth buying back at every
opportunity
buy back it's not called out for 20
seconds they've got a window of 20
seconds but they've lost the e they've
lost bone 7 clutcher trying to break
down big daddy but big daddy he's a big
pig quista cleaning up that's the
earthshaker zeus down but buy back in
ten seconds couldn't they do anything
divine rape is a drop no we're back okay
reset finally by the end of it sfc ended
up winning sending the series to game
three they're trying to chase down the
rest but bristle back he stays back it
keeps back into the fight they're gonna
go for the tier fours they're on the hs
there isn't any fortification it's gonna
be
and smc they win fill with the game oh
my god on the plus side thanks to od
pixel and purge's iconic casting the
game has been immortalized as one of the
most insane and hilarious matches in
dota 2 history it's just in a total
deadlock but
do we get a bathroom breaker
i mean mate if you need to go and
relieve yourself i'm just kidding
coming in at number six is the coolest
man in esports it's shocked with his
record for the most clutches in cs go he
can get a lot done from this position if
they don't count him here but there are
three players coming around the corner
someone's going to hit the shot and they
do response from shocks time is low he's
got a second the models are burning and
shocks is setting him alive four kills
for shocks pulling off any clutch in cs
go makes you want to throw chalk in the
air like lebron even when it happens in
your silver comp match now imagine your
shocks and have
741 clutches in pro matches to your name
741 is a truly outrageous number it's
honestly pretty difficult to put into
words how incredible this record is so
it's probably better if we just show you
i twist meanwhile
he should be the safety net no one's
looking no one's looking they lost track
but they have recovered nicely they're
shocked continuing to spray trying to
find everything it's just stewie left
he's got it i think he's got the defuse
as well i think he's got plenty of time
has been in the game for a long time but
his ability to produce when outnumbered
is a testament to his level of skill and
shows just how long he's proved himself
as one of the greats
and number five spot has been
exclusively reserved by esports biggest
ballers oh gee
don't be afraid
[Applause]
now if you haven't already heard this
group of multinational dota 2 pros take
up spots 1 through 5 for highest
tournament earnings in esports history
collectively these five lads have raked
in over 30 million dollars this of
course is all thanks to winning two very
important tournaments back to back
[Music]
ti's prize money includes a fraction of
that year's battle pass sales and every
year so far the tournament has beat
itself for the highest prize pool in
esports those two tournaments set these
boys up for life i still think it's so
unfair that an on-rank carry player wins
t.i sorry
wasn't intentional it takes a true stone
cold killer to secure the record that
takes our fourth spot and that goes to
the hungry man himself snacks with the
most kills in csgo
does find one let's not leave him out of
this the big apple and snacks is hungry
he's got one kill already on the usp
low hp as well on guardian and flame
he's trying to bait them out trying to
get them into one on ones as he dances
back and forth between the box what a
shot on simple oh guardian bye-bye
and it's on the flamey he's tapped in
flame he's got a big
what in god's name is that from stacks
now this record has been in contention
for a long time with the likes of kenny
s and forrest holding the lead at some
point that being said at the time of
recording the polish powerhouse is the
king of kills with 37
498 franks to his name snax has been
playing professional cs go for almost
eight and a half years he's a certified
member of the old guard but this major
winning monster hasn't slowed down one
bit it's gonna go all the flash timing
is perfect taco gets him down no chance
for passion to strike nice shot snacks
up close
and a straight flash high in the sky
they won't be able to dodge means he can
go back for more and he certainly will
finds a second and a third stacks on
fire what a shot as he picks up a fence
for vertis pro to close the half now
snacks might not be able to hold on to
this record forever but that almost
makes it more exciting it's a battle
between the og's of counter-strike and
the new blood to see who's gonna be the
all-time top fragger
slaughtering the competition to naba
third spot is chovey and his 100 plus
kda there it is crashing down anchovy
wants to find it fantastic taunt and
that's the 100 kda but will he go down
right afterwards the answer he's most
likely knows viper he's bouncing around
the fight eventually he does fall down
but it's all for not a sword dives on
forward and faker is killed trophy gets
the full zoom first ever player to hit
100 kda trophy is one of the greatest
mid laners to ever touch league of
legends he's an unassuming shy kid who
just so happens to be a mechanical god
and an absolute killer afrika freaks
want to be able to find this baron and
it probably has to be how can griffin
stop it not entirely sure papa jovi's
moving over tarzan has barely
tripping
he doesn't get it as tarzan gets so much
back from the kitchen oh that shockwave
is corrupt cannot do anything to answer
and griffin they may have just won the
game of the basketball tournament that's
the double kill twosome he's looking for
more and there's the triple
as a result of chobi's dominance on the
rift he became the first and so far only
pro in league to reach a kda over 100
it's no surprise that someone who's able
to outsmart the likes of faker is the
only person to reach this incredible
milestone
131 is there toby baker
wants to see see you later but he's
under shroud and toby he's actually
gonna outplay him just don't go around
calling him chokey you've seen what he
can do yeah they managed to get this
inhibitor turret most likely as well as
the siege minion is going to be down
toby has a lot of sneakiness diving on
forward and bono didn't last a couple of
seconds he's going 1v4 lava is going to
be the first one to go down
it's going to be tagged up but no
backflip going to be reactivated anchovy
the two for one before
the runner-up spot now is dedicated to
valerian's most insane record it's
vision strikers and their 102
series professional win streak they're
trying to go for the defuse right now
godlike is doing it again they need to
stop them and they will be able to stop
them just barely as they're pushing out
they have half the diffuse but i don't
think it's going to be enough
he's not going to have enough time he
goes down and vision strikers will take
the 3-0 victory from the start of their
professional debut vision strikers went
on to win 102 matches in a row without
losing but they did pick up a few ties
here and there they dominated the korean
baron scene and all the rest of the
world could do was watch in fear and
wait for their chance to challenge the
apac gods uh going into a and i think
they just blew my god rp
puts himself straight in there the
double blast back into the showstopper
what a stylish way to end it
unfortunately vision striker's run was
finally cut short in april 2021 and soon
after their streak ended they lost some
key games and missed out on valorum's
first international land we spot his gun
for just a moment god dead taking some
shots he gets king through the wall
can he get the final one he wants it
he's got it the king is dead long live
the king
from streamers to godslayers f4q
complete their david goliath story you
were here you witnessed the end of a
dynasty despite the unfortunate outcome
a 102 series win streak is an
unbelievable accomplishment and it's
unlikely that any team in any region
will be able to show the same dominance
that vision strikers once did
okay our last entry was incredible but
for our top spot we have to give it up
to the ogs of cs go it's ninjas in
pajamas with the longest map streak on
lan we had this amazing run in the
beginning we won every single tournament
87 straight games in a row without the
single loss now before you tell us that
102 is a bigger number than 87 we know
but nip's record is very different from
our previous entry you see vision
strikers may have won 102 games in a row
but they dropped plenty of maps along
the way nip on the other hand didn't
drop a single land map from late 2012 to
early 2013. they were unbeatable
[Applause]
now there are some detractors that
downplay nip streak due to how green cs
goes competitive scene was at the time
but it's not like zeus and neo were just
some dudes that wanted to give cs go a
while most of nip's opponents were
legitimate competitors that just
couldn't find an answer for months
nip's win streak actually helped shape
the way the competitive scene is today
they were the first team to really
practice set plays and other teams
eventually had to follow suit any team
worth their salt today spends countless
hours practicing and perfecting new
strats just like n.i.p did to capture
this untouchable record well those were
our top 10 records guys were there any
records that you think should have made
it onto the list let me know also let me
know what you want to see next on the
channel thanks for watching and i'll see
you all in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you